as sweet shooting in parkland Florida
has sparked renewed demands for gun
control across the country of course
America's gun ownership rate used to be
a lot higher than it is today
deadly school shootings are mostly a
recent phenomenon
what has changed could it be our overall
culture is not undergone a toxic shift
Matt Bevin is the governor of the
Commonwealth of Kentucky recently
suggested that violent video games and
TV shows have created a quote
desensitized culture governor joins us
take governor thanks coming up great to
be on with you doctor so um that is kind
of the question I mean fewer American
households own guns than did 50 years
ago and yet we didn't have school
shootings what do you think the
difference is between then and now I
think the thing is to ask ourselves what
has changed because your point is
well-taken if gun ownership itself has
not changed and if in fact it's not
there are more gun restrictions now
there are more rules about who can or
can't own a gun or how a gun might be
acquired then there were fifty and a
hundred years ago and yet fifty and a
hundred years ago children did not
slaughter other children at school what
has changed it isn't the gun so
something culturally has changed and I
would submit that we have become
significantly desensitized to death into
violence and we are training children
whether we intend to or not whether it's
anyone's desire or not through video
games through movies through musical
lyrics through mood television shows
increasingly during primetime even the
amount of violence is increasingly
realistic increasingly graphic and there
is a cost to this you couple that with
the number of psychiatric drugs that
children and adults for that matter are
on and the number of warnings about
depression and suicidal thoughts
a couple all that with the fact that our
mores as a society have shifted to the
degree that they're largely non-existent
that we no longer have these clear
delineated right and wrong boundaries
that everything is somewhat gelatinous
and these children are increasingly
coming from broken homes as well and
they find themselves rudderless then
you're a father and you understand it's
important
what happens at home has a profound
impact on what your children do out
there too many children don't have the
blessings of having a stable environment
at home and we have to look at what has
changed in society and not have a
knee-jerk response that another rule and
another regulation is the answer
so everything you've said makes sense I
haven't seen the social science on it
but it doesn't sound crazy at all it
seems kind of obvious why if you could
just sum up quickly why do you think
saying what you just said get such a
hostile reaction from a lot of people
why do they hate to hear that it does
not fit the narrative that people want
and for a thousand reasons people have a
preconceived notion that another gun
restriction for example another rule and
other regulation another you can't do
this another governmental intervention
of some sort is the answer when in fact
nobody wants to look at what they have
to look at if it's not that and that is
what our responsibility is in society as
individuals as parents as teachers as
educators as people in the churches and
civic organizations and youth
organizations what are we not doing that
was done a generation ago to provide the
type of guidance that young people need
as they grow up in not the least of
which is how you deal with differences
of opinion and I'll tell you one other
thing too that I've not said although
I'm sure this will make people's heads
explode in some regard as well we are we
are lionizing sadly some of these
children who do this again
not any one's intention but we're making
heroes of a child who has no business to
have their face put out there another
young person who's in the balance
perhaps psychologically unbalanced is
going to say why not
I'll get my 15 minutes worth of fame if
we don't think that there's a copycat
mentality we're not paying attention
that's the nature of the Internet
governor thank you that was really
interesting I appreciate it
thank you Lieutenant Colonel Dave
Grossman is the author of the book
assassination generation and he joins us
tonight
colonel thanks coming on so you've done
more great hey you don't you just said
yeah you haven't seen the social science
on it yet here it is well that's right
that's why I want to talk to you so
so the
is the kind of idea that gets de Miss
dismissed as cranky immediately by
people who know nothing
the idea that violent weather usually
entertainment right well that's exactly
right so what do we know about what is
the social science what is the evidence
the AMA the APA the American Academy of
pediatric surgeon Dental laughter
Surgeon General made definitive
statements with the matter of pain
before the Supreme Court California law
to regulate children's access to violent
video games the video game industry
found 82 journalism professor I think
about 82 Media Studies professors who
told the Supreme Court there is no
scientific proof it was academic
malfeasance at the highest level our
entire medical community scream it from
the mountainside one of the dissenting
justices in the Supreme Court case said
I'm not a medical expert who is and it's
not 82 journalism professors our entire
medical community thousands of sound
scholarly so telling us anybody I'd less
rather take advice from than journalism
professor I can't imagine a Dumber group
of people malfeasance of journalism
professors making a joint statement to
the Supreme Court but talking here's
what's important please look at this it
was 2002 an identical crime happened in
Germany 19 year-old high school dropout
in effort to remedy murder 17 people at
school identical crime Germany 2002 it's
not about the guns Germany can't stop it
we saw this weekend a massacre in a
church in Russia Russia's are
totalitarian nation that's right dick
fronts come stood every gun for a
century and they can't stop evil people
getting guns the most horrific juvenile
mass murder in history a 70 year old kid
in 2009 in bitten in Germany murdered 15
people Germany can't stop it Russia
can't stop it it's not about taking away
rights well I noticed that but more
right but why are the media is so
hesitant to go after the big businesses
that are profiting from this garbage
that's a question I'd like to explore
their interface and their
no no no it's their donor base and their
voter base they know that they've lost
that gun owner
they know that they've lost those votes
and and to attack the gunner agenda
specially to protect the videogame
industry this is their donor base well
that's that's exactly right
Lieutenant Colonel thank you I
appreciate it and I agree with you hey
one last thing Tucker like yeah we're
teaching the kids that we need sheepdogs
out there we don't need more wolves we
don't need more chief we need sheepdogs
I originated the whole sheepdog concept
the sheepdog kids book assassination
Federation were changed for the world
Tucker there's hope for America it
begins with you thank you for what you
do
I appreciate thanks